DOW GAINED 410.
S&P 500 UP 36.
NASDAQ JUMPED 107.
LET’S TALK ABOUT THE BUSINESS OF
THE BUDGET AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
SENIOR POLITICAL ANALYST
BRIT HUME.
IN THE BUDGET AND THE THOUGHT
THAT REPUBLICANS ARE IN A
DIFFERENT PLACE THAN THEY WERE
IN RECENT YEARS ABOUT CONCERN
ABOUT SPENDING AND CRITICISM
FROM MORE CONSERVATIVE MEMBERS
SAYING THIS IS SPENDING THROUGH
THE ROOF.
>> WELL, IT CERTAINLY LOOKS THAT
WAY.
THAT’S THE CRITICISM YOU’RE
GOING TO HEAR.
REMINDS ME OF WHAT HAPPENED IN
THE EARLY YEARS OF THE REAGAN
ADMINISTRATION WHEN THE
PRESIDENT PUSHED THROUGH AN
ENORMOUS TAX CUT.
A GREAT DEAL WAS SPENT ON THE
AMERICAN MILITARY.
AT THE TIME THE BIG DRIVER OF
DOMESTIC SPENDING WAS NOT THE
DISCRETIONARY STUFF THAT WE ARE
ENTITLEMENT SPENDING.
THE PRESIDENT MADE AN EFFORT,
TOOK A STAB AT GETTING SOMETHING
DONE.
HE DIDN’T REALLY SUCCEED.
NO ONE REALLY HAS SINCE.
THE PRESIDENT IN THIS INSTANCE
HAS BASICALLY TAKEN IT OFF THE
TABLE.
WE ARE FIGHTING HERE ABOUT
WHETHER IT’S POSSIBLE TO RAISE
MILITARY SPENDING WHICH NEARLY
EVERY REPUBLICAN AND EVERYONE IN
THE MILITARY SAYS IS ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY WITHOUT RAISING
DOMESTIC SPENDING TO BRING ALONG
DEMOCRATIC VOTES.
THOSE HOUSE MEMBERS WHO ARE
CRITICIZING THE DEAL HAVE YET TO
EXPLAIN HOW IT’S POSSIBLE WHEN
YOU NEED 60 VOTES IN THE SENATE
AND YOU HAVE 51 REPUBLICANS,
THAT YOU CAN PUSH THROUGH HIGHER
MILITARY SPENDING WITHOUT ALSO
RAISING DOMESTIC SPINNING.
JORDAN AND THE OTHERS VOTED FOR
THE
THE BIG TAX CUT WHICH EVERYBODY
SEEMS TO WANT BUT IT LEAVES US
WHERE YOU HAVE THIS ARGUMENT
OVER SPENDING AND WHEN THEY CAN
EXPLAIN, WHEN THE CRITICS CAN
EXPLAIN HOW IT IS THAT WE CAN
SPEND MONEY ON THE MILITARY NOT
GET UP SOME ON DOMESTIC, THEY
NEED TO SAY HOW IT WOULD WORK.
>> Bret: I THINK THE CAMERA IS
IN AGREEMENT.
>> THE CAMERA IS NODDING.
>> Bret: LET ME ASK ABOUT YOUR
PERCEPTION OF THE WHITE HOUSE
ISSUE AND THE ROB PORTER
SITUATION.
HOW IT WAS HANDLED, HOW MESSY IT
IS AND WHERE DO YOU THINK IT
GOES?
>> IT HASN’T BEEN HANDLED SO
MUCH AS BUNGLED.
NECESSARY INFORMATION APPARENTLY
NEVER REACHED THE INFORMATION
WHO NEEDED TO DECIDE THAT MAYBE
HAVING THIS GUY AROUND WAS NOT A
GOOD IDEA.
I CAN UNDERSTAND HOW ONE WOULD
BE SYMPATHETIC TO THE IDEA THAT
IF SOMEONE IS MERELY ACCUSED, AS
HAS BEEN SUGGESTED IN THIS CASE,
THAT HE SHOULDN’T AUTOMATICALLY
BE DRUMMED OUT OF POLITE SOCIETY
BUT IN THIS INSTANCE WE HAD NOT
ONE WOMAN ALLEGING ABUSE BUT TWO
EX-WIVES AND THEIR PHOTOGRAPHS.
IT SHOULD RAISE A LOT OF ALARMS.
APPARENTLY THE ALARMS WERE
PROPERLY RAISED OR THE PEOPLE
SHOULD HAVE HEARD THE ALARMS
DIDN’T RESPOND.
THEN YOU HAVE THE PROBLEM THAT
THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF IN
RESPONDING HAS BEEN DEFENSIVE OF
HIS NOW DEPARTED AID.
UNDERSTANDABLE ON THE HUMAN
LEVEL BUT HE HAS YET TO SAY
ANYTHING HE HAS MUCH SYMPATHY
FOR THE WOMEN INVOLVED WHICH
WILL FEED INTO THE NARRATIVE
THAT THIS GUY IS SOME KIND OF
MISOGYNIST.
WHETHER THAT IS TRUE OR NOT, IT
MAKES IT LOOK THAT WAY.
>> Bret: HE HASN’T SAID.
>> HE PERSONALLY HASN’T SAID A
WORD.
I HEARD SARAH SANDERS SAY THAT
TODAY.
THAT SHE WAS SPEAKING FOR HIM
WHEN HE EXPRESSED CONCERN BUT
THERE IS NO SUBSTITUTE IN
CERTAIN CASES WITH THE WORD
COMING FROM THE PRINCIPAL.
>> Bret: DO YOU THINK
WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF JOHN
KELLY IS IN JEOPARDY?
>> I WOULD BE SURPRISED IF YOU
WERE.
IF THE PRESIDENT IS CHAFING
UNDER THE RESTRICTIVE OPERATION
KELLY HAS WISELY IMPOSED ON THE
WHITE HOUSE, HE MIGHT USE THIS
AS AN EXCUSE TO GET RID OF HIM
BUT I DON’T THINK THAT’S GOING
TO HAPPEN.
I THINK IT WOULD BE A SERIOUS
LOSS TO THE NATION EVICTED
BECAUSE THE DISCIPLINE THAT HAS
BEEN IMPOSED UNDER KELLY HAS
BEEN VERY BADLY NEEDED, AND